hi there Steve Kaufman here I got a new
microphone hopefully this resolves the
sound problem I'm gonna speak today in
Chinese there won't be any transcript
there won't be any translation but I'm
gonna talk about more or less the same
subject in my next regular video which
will have a transcript and will be in
English I'm gonna talk about the
importance of reading and the importance
of a large vocabulary in order to be
able to read things that are meaningful
and just how important this whole idea
of working with texts and input has been
in language learning throughout history
your Durance wanna say yes yes you shall
now go Jawa Peter Xiao Shu that regard
so vilya Chloe layout you can told the
don't supporters should table with all
the neighbor's dog Bailey out here what
don't refund radiation comfort waist
Amana you may swear I'm equally sure
[ __ ] who be insane teacher T de take a
pin video P de su John Yaeger learned I
can a Rhonda Tata shoe Pierre saw said
who bien de if I were sure that's a car
no way John de Cobo daughter named the
passenger who sure
- Ana whether she each answer with
gender bath and your t-shirt - your net
sick - now this is pooja Nega the in add
of yes No janeshia Cantigny Rho theta y
o1 c da nasha nasha Donna should be
charged a higher honor the yes yes sir
cut yet shall fetch Antonio he got us
the father you know you can't order you
a new nama yo yet Peter you're either
your is can only me we can sing she knew
pa PC Janet others you wish ya Yin job
they're sure they're wrong in you young
you endure the combination Tito yoga BT
opening the Shrew job
Ulysses to an usher James Joyce Tolly
toner check so that to Julia
shoot sir actually by one Tiger Ta'ala
someone to put on the zoo so he can
James Joyce Scioscia de even you in when
a girl when she hit other honey Yan Ming
they worship me teaching someone little
now whether put a bandage on in when me
[ __ ] are John vanishes on dodging
Yorkin when she miss Osie other should
be mrs. Jean de kado conseguir Ganesha -
will either take Eamon time
baba yaga way woman John
she ended England now come on your
Hedorah
what we can that Kingdom Oh belong true
ha now the never swallow me hey cut me
quickest Ramadan she better
Nanaia powder like an eco you can show
to the butcher leader
condoned in about Rama never eating
powder not even de
powder put him on the powder cardigan
yonder Nagar sleeping child or sir
toosha choose in Eng de rigueur
shrieking sure is unsuitable
whoa morose generally way another
[ __ ] yet mean by the one here see
sure wait Shama you may what ja Rule 20
she's your your sink potentially sure
did you know they were either you either
way okay
yeah condom no but I look at it on your
heater narrow how you're sure all by a
vendor sensor die from just solutions
how a tiny man named Julie taught Russia
Anna Nagar to see Anna nega nega pin Lou
connacher Elia Sansa dildo Hans agenda
truly the pin you sure he eats Alianza
sons undulator
a Chan Chan soo tae ji dancer Lee Teuk
the back into sunshine soil so he near
centimeter you eat a shoe yeah hunched
over the car nah need a job - G - we
found a by furniture polish on the dig a
second you had orange aura never know
what a link can they don't narrow
branches okay charge the N key parts
when a girlish under savage a coochie
coo
doctor one I pursue Mayo the cat ear now
live under one banner shubra what they
travel by a beautiful pie Samba
psycho a shoe the controversial non go
can i ponder when she least respond
Peter you eat sooner 20 [ __ ] you sure
she's written you're bound ruler cousin
email Tom another they got so Villanova
in to bucola sorry Nigel - wha so Villa
the Tony Ossian are here
wait a moment link JC seed oh yeah sure
Peter Chung sure soon-ja so Villa take
money haha nah not a whole weeaboo
shibuya so William see our condo
pinnacle Dodger Tommy Lee NJ so we add
er er nice mayor's Meridian
Mayor Mark Wright is visible
cheerio can you and daughter together
you had you had you had to hurt Tinh Tai
Chloe run Donna see granny like a cinder
year time Omega T Bo need your car to
chauffeur or its actual harder Sharona -
Tony Argentina Leo jet to a France or
Ottawa Sydney has shorted you started to
Ming back to a short one
take me with an angle wanted the kingdom
by 2 alpha didn't we pass short one will
Jake thousand a room shaitan on
co-pilots so very ad agency action yeah
so nice okay turn tarde ha ha